I mentioned this I don't even know if
the dinettes knew about this but I told
them I'd gone fly-fishing a couple of
times I've been in British Columbia I'd
been in Scotland and I'd been in Ireland
and two of those trips I went with one
of the best fly fishermen in the world
and the show is called fly fishing the
world and John Barrett's a hall-of-famer
and the British Columbia trip was
awesome because we were able to go and
you're in this remote part of the world
and you take on those planes that lands
on the water we stayed in this King
Pacific lodge there and saw whales
breaching it was it was really a
remarkable trip and I lost touch with
John Barrett in fact my brother and I
who he went with me on the trip I didn't
know how to get ahold of John Barrett we
started talking about fly fishing and
then Mario said hey John Barrett called
in I said well have John call back as I
want to talk to him in the hall of famer
John Barrett joins us hey John
hi Dan I know I'd lost track we tried to
my brother and I tried to track you down
just to see how you're doing and lo and
behold we bring up fly-fishing of course
as we always do on this program but
congrats on being in the Hall of Fame
did they see the video of me out fishing
you on the fly fishing the world trip in
British Columbia you know I don't think
they did but I'll tell you what's gonna
cost me more than anything is when I go
play poker with my buddies they heard of
you out fly-fishing me yes and and
that's probably true I hate to admit it
you didn't get upset you got upset that
day right well I think that's part of
being a good host is to make your guests
appear better than they are and I did
that for 22 years so it's like throwing
a game or taking a dive you allowed me
to catch all of the big fish
okay well they're gonna say you're a
Hall of Fame status might be in doubt
right now John I thought it was
wonderful and you were kind enough and
patient enough to teach me how to
fly-fish and your ability I mean that's
why you're in the Hall of Fame but I had
so much fun and then I told these guys
that I also got to see one of the more
one of the rarer animals in the world
the komoti bear the spirit bear on that
same trip to British Columbia
so I out fish a little Famer and then I
got to see the komoti bear do you
remember the photographer Mark Muench
yeah the guy who took my photos that I
took when I'm 15 feet away from this
deadly bear that one yes and then he
made it into a calendar yeah he's making
money off of off of you but but you
remember how close I was to that bear
accidentally because you guys left me
alone and I'm taking all these photos of
this bear that's probably 7 feet tall
and then I look around and you guys have
left me well we put you I remember
putting on the shore and then we took
off in the boat to go to the other side
of where the river entered the bay yeah
and thinking the bear had crossed the
river away from you I know so you
handled it with grace I just kept taking
photos I right I mean that's what the
great ones do you I risk life and limb
how long would it take you to teach mine
if we come to Missoula Montana I'm
assuming that's where you still are
right okay if I bring the damage there
and we sort of do a Brad Pitt River runs
through it type day how long would it
take you to make them respectable one
day that's a long pause John listen I
can teach anybody to cast well enough to
catch fish in a couple of hours okay
it's not easy I remember Danny Ainge one
time said fly-fishing was the hardest
board he ever tried and this is a guy
who played pro baseball and basketball
it can be challenging it can be really
challenging but you taken a lot of
celebrities out yet I mean this was the
beauty of your show that I think he did
it for 20 years but you know Liam Neeson
I think Kevin Costner Bob Knight Robert
Duvall Dan Patrick you know some of the
big names Michael Keaton Walter Payton
I took bait in the very first year I did
shows I did shows with God golfers
seemed to be really good at fly-fishing
Paul Azinger and Nick Faldo Johnny
Miller Jack Nicklaus they were all good
Michael Keaton is very good I was just
fishing with Liam Neeson no cameras
couple weeks ago in Montana he just
finished a movie in Ireland and I
invited and become fishing they flew to
Montana and we spent about five days
fishing so well I'd love to connect with
you again and kick your ass
whether there's cameras rolling or not
John I mean what does call it the
rematch I mean whatever it doesn't
matter yeah this time I won't play host
okay yeah you don't have to teach me
anything maybe I get really well I will
admit that you know you it's tougher
it's tough to go up and fish in areas
like the place we were fishing and
there's Columbia because you got to
throw the fly line a good you know 30 40
yards or 30 40 feet to catch fish and
you picked it up quick thank you John
I'd like to stay in touch with you and
get your number there so stay on hold so
I can get that and great to catch up
with you again John thank you I will
he's listening now that's John Barrett
he's a hall-of-famer for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]